right Galileo is at 45 days that's
that's no biggie that's fine hypatia has
been promoted so we can either fire
twice effectively if we want or by
firing somebody we make up allies more
accurate mm oh no other depends suppose
um but you know what's a fire twice
would be really useful term weeks plus
ten Amy she's got like 70 so that's
adding it's not insignificant but I'm
gonna give the bullets warm partly
because it just has the cooler name
right and keppra support the support
class provides the intangible edge our
squads need they make everyone around
them better the intangible edge does
that make sense i'm not sure it does
okay smoke grenade cool new research
carapace armor now that's a sight for
sore eyes look actually recovered flight
computer of damaged power source and how
many weapon fragments 10 so we've got
plenty to be getting on with well
research cool no money though they
didn't have any cash on them apparently
okay that's gonna be a limiting factor
this month I think okay let's just have
a check on our soldiers actually we've
got Carolina Hershel here james hughes
tell you what this actually gives you an
opportunity to have a look at how
customize our soldiers so we have a
british physicist from this period let
me have a think mmm
sorry I'm having to reach my own room my
microphone because I've got a really
scrubby set up Isaac Newton your white
of course because basically everyone in
this video series will be that's just a
that Western what that's basically where
the history physics gone what do you
sound like Newton yeah that sounds about
right head Newton was like he looked
like Benedict Cumberbatch it's so
horrifying watching their features more
that doesn't look unlike Benedict
Cumberbatch so let's go with that hair
he had like the Brian May hairstyle so
I'm not sure we could add it oh I know I
know yes we can there we go he sorry I
keep right clicking that's that that's
the Brian may right there that this is
the guile actually from the original so
geil wasn't from the original that scum
but original at Scott they all had hair
cuts like this and it was amazing facial
hair Newton's clean-shaven let's make
her arm of the same as anyone else hair
color he was great and I don't think
there's own I do yeah there you go
that's fine but Isaac Newton everyone
Isaac Newton oh okie dokie we'll get
around to you talking about you in the
future okay
engineering can we ask us money we've
got med kits oh so we should okay right
well let's use all that money to build
some of these and let's go to our
soldiers and we're going to equip
Hypatia is too valuable to not have one
load out oh how do you how do you give
them at right okay oh so it instantly
made them okay let's think about this a
second then so we have it oh you
actually got the full classes that's
good so support it would make sense if
you had a medikit Hypatia you're heavy
so you are probably just going to come
under a lot of fire so I'd rather you
were something they'll keep you alive
Newton is a sniper because he was he got
quite a few kills on the the first
mission so sniper
probably the five of us again I think
it's that's what you can't really go too
far wrong with that Kepler you've got
the medikit and Copernicus your assault
I'm no but a grenade now you're
definitely a new one of those okay I
only having one medic it's making me a
little bit nervous we'll see okay right
that's good we kitted out our soldiers
let's see if we can find some mess to
clean up oh right okay let's try over
the UK and india are um commander panic
we tracking several reported abductions
via the challah globe I've got the
coordinates locked in okay acapulco
forget any sniper at sergeant level
which is basic which is the level that I
pay [ __ ] out ah or 200 x200 big ones but
it's difficult um hmm oh I don't know
we're fine we don't want some casual
coming in you know I just don't think we
need the engine is I think we just got
to buy to go for Australia it's gonna be
difficult but oh yeah the panic level
mmm yeah let's go for it I'm gonna
regret this we are gonna need our best
men Galileo let's just see you're still
a rookie so let's get rid of you and
let's add in Isaac Newton oh my god oh I
got that hair right our dream team
Copernicus I paycheck Epler and neaten
these are the men and women and women
that are saving the planet
oh boy right also see in a sent an umber
of requests for assistance so that's our
next drop not what the local broadcast
is skating alien activity within a major
metropolitan area we should get down
there and eliminate any hostiles so
collateral damage is not okay there no
civilians right okay because there are
Terra missions where you actually have
to say civilians nothing funny though I
would rather just leave the aliens to
the Australian wildlife because if in
war the world's just earth so microbes
in general was enough to just see off
the alien menace surely Australia which
is very much the most dangerous place on
the planet that we've more than enough
okay remember this is a dangerous one so
where's our snow your support that's
Newton Copernicus you're our assault guy
all the sound effects are willing me out
again it's all about good positioning
and overlapping fields of fire it really
really is oh no sorry mitts Dave wash
right Copernicus notice keep you okay
I'm gonna take a risk I pass him we've
up okay suneet ins got much much bigger
range than anyone else it might be an
idea to put him on top of start maybe
but then he's very very vulnerable
oh you can't go in overwatch because
you're the sniper class no oh I didn't
mean to do that that was really really
dumb bollocks I just uses unique ability
and I've put him in a really bad
position and you're completely flanked
oh but you can't overwash oh that's
something right system alien nonsense
going on that we can't see yes come on
come on it was a shotgun to show uh sure
although actually that distance I've
shot quite a few shotguns in my time oh
you got lucky that's gonna explode no I
shot quite a few shotguns of my time and
you'd still be able to hear that kind of
distance so that that's some [ __ ]
right let's move you up here oh okay
this is fine this is fine we are the
best soldiers and the best physicist in
the world well you can do this
Copernicus is actually the next guy that
I want to talk about we did again we did
a feature on him on the science hour and
he he was rather remarkable in sort of
just just just Western history because
he was pretty much one of the first
times that somebody stood up to come on
come on yes yeah what basically the
first person to stand up to the most
powerful organization at the time which
was the Catholic Church and openly
defiant because he the famous thing that
Copernicus did was he it was
heliocentrism right so before Copernicus
oh my god Hypatia is like a murderer I I
wouldn't want to sleep in a room with
her like that she's terrifying kept us
but you've got the medikit so that's
probably a good place for you actually
let's put your name forward neaten can't
do anything from there mustache you up
here all right what do we need to have
any cover so that your yellow half
shield men he didn't have any cover that
oh okay that's not so bad like you just
hunkering down that's great that was
some [ __ ] right there that was
grade-a [ __ ]
can we see you're being supported by
that guy over there Kepler so that is
because I've got the medikit if I do
that he's more resilient so that's let's
see if we can save a life and do do the
fray thing okay Hypatia kid got kill him
close enough oh maybe I should stop
talking about that's like the scientists
because it seems whenever I start
talking about them they will just die
okay we should not panicked right we
cured a running gun I just don't think
that's a very good idea Newton can't see
[ __ ] and heat the thing because he's a
sniper he can't move and fire I pay sure
if we mmm
I can't see what happened oh okay so
she's hit that's not ideal all right
let's just think about this logically
that guy at the moment has got a pretty
clear shot on Copernicus and in return
he's not got very much okay right so our
options are we could shoot two alien one
she's heading to or we could pull back
to here given that she's injured I'm
rather gonna prefer caution here thing
is we need to be shielded from this do
as well if we can get Newton to their
next time you can shoot
sudhir we just run her and yeah do it
let's run home that right it's Kepler I
am really not feeling so great about
Copernicus's chances of survival let's
do I need to hear right this was this
was a difficult mission after all yeah
okay car moving fire so hunker down
Kepler let's hear that Copernicus
apparently by spraying with links on him
okay neaten what can your elf I see I'll
come on that's [ __ ] now can I use
that again or is that a one usability I
don't think I can
right so here can you see over the so
what we can do if we can get hypatius at
her she's got a good come on take him
out yes okay she needs to reload that's
no big deal there's another anything
over there at least one more alien if we
run I don't think he can heal anyone
else I think he's now basically just
another soldier all right I neaten is
apparently blind um good left shift is
pretty okay sees anyone left to do
anything we may as well put them on
overwatch let's see what they do come on
needs and take a shot nope apparently
can't see anything right okay so yes
what I was saying about that's Kepler
Copernicus over it yeah he he related
this idea called heliocentrism which is
the idea that the Sun is the center of
the known universe so at the universe at
the time the known universe was just the
solar system the idea before that was
called a Ptolemaic system which had that
the the earth was at the center of the
solar system now this was an idea that
had existed since the time of Ptolemy so
given that this was happening in the
16th and yeah the 16th century it
existed for getting on for 2,000 years
and the Catholic Church adopted it as
being true this is a problem because the
Catholic Church was by far the most
powerful organization in Europe at the
time and anybody who defied them was
effectively committing heresy Oh Kepler
come on and to define them you know that
that was huge because a religion was far
more important factoring people's
I've stem Buddhist today obviously is
still very important to some people but
back then they were the single most
important organization in well in in the
Western world so I go against them you
can imagine that that's effectively it's
like doing what Edward Snowden did but
more really ah Tao gotta reload all
right um try it ten percent chance come
on okay Newton can't see anything oh I
did realize that was that what that
shortcut did how do you skip 10 Oh
backspace
oh I don't like that et in sight I love
that and it was basically it was only
through a series of connections that
Copernicus had to oh I remember his name
but there was a very particular Cardinal
he he was working for that he was able
to really get away with what the stuff
he was saying sorry I'm just thinking
you know it's a big deal and it was
basically the first time that in Western
history that an individual was able to
do that and was able to basically
advance something beyond the religious
and being this idea of superstition and
actually apply mathematical truths and
science to and in really nicholas
Nicholas Copernicus only was it was the
Copernican revolution of the healer
centuries and revolution that
kick-started the Scientific Revolution
and nice work Kepler that um that yeah
that kick-started what we now know is
modern science and deconstructing the
world into quantifiable sciences so I
owe my job to nicholas copernicus and
pretty much every single scientist in
the series that's gonna be fighting owes
their yeah Oh is there that feels to him
he's an incredibly important guy how can
you not see anyone Newton are you bloody
blind you're the worst sniper in history
right my patient's gonna go on overwatch
there's another one over there okay oh
come on uh you can't win them all
Hypatia she's won the very few people
whose nationalities actually matches up
with the National see on the back oh
that didn't look good that trucks gonna
explode
so let's run in here let's hope there's
no more aliens after this guy right in
the face how did you miss